is uh going to face his fellow dutchman
jordan van forest tomorrow so a good
night's sleep for a niche and he should
be ready to fight again tomorrow one
match is still going on it's uh
shakhrian mamilyarov against eric hansen
this is game four they are tied if we
have a winner in this game then that
player will win the match if it is a
draw then tie breaks and what does it
look like right now david it's still
very early days uh we are just towards
the end of the petrov defence
which is one of the most solid openings
out there in chess manager of just
trying to maybe lock this game down as
black that being said eric didn't go for
any drawish lines he's instead gone for
a position that we see in front of us
where every piece is still on the board
a couple of open files in the middle but
uh roughly balanced right now
uh any preference
you guys have i mean you think it's
better right now i mean i was just
thinking from eric's uh situation he's
lost his first two batches and you only
get any money from this if you win or if
you draw out before games so
if i was in his position that'd be on
the back of my brain because i'd be like
right okay if i draw this this game as
white i'm guaranteed some cash take it
into the playoffs he's got the white
pieces and i i i think it is equal and i
just hope he doesn't play it's not like
eric to play negatively but he's just
got to play normal moves but i mean even
having those little thoughts and these
last games can affect affect your play
quite a lot i feel
yeah and uh i mean it'll be tough for
eric to go against this natural
instincts and just play for the draw but
i completely understand that simon i i'd
probably do the same just safety first
don't take too much risk in this game
and tie breaks aren't the worst thing in
the world um i think actually you'll be
quite close in the blitz thai breaks
because eric is really good at that time
format so yeah we'll see how this is
yeah i'm going to say eric is well known
for his uh speed prowess whilst the
shakira mama jaroff you know he he
himself told me that up until recently
he wasn't playing online chess and now
he's playing catch-up
so i mean but both these players i mean
they're incredible tacticians so
yeah it would be an exciting yeah
exciting i'm definitely i believe race
that would be super fun yeah i remember
when uh covered first came and it was
locked down everywhere and i played
quite a lot online myself and i faced uh
shaq quite a few times my major of and i
could tell he was a bit rusty he was a
bit slower than most of the top ground
masters the moves were still of course
really good but the speed wasn't there
uh in the blitz
uh but now of course he's probably has
caught up and
that would be so dramatic i mean we
didn't we never hoped for draws right
but this would be a fun tie break to
watch between these two and i mean well
it looks like eric's about to retreat
his bishop
yeah i mean very sensible player at the
moment uh it's a symmetrical kind of
position both pieces are are quite
logical i mean i want to play rook takes
bishop here of course
but i probably shouldn't um so you know
i have that a lot why why why should you
not take the bishop well i i mean
basically rooks are better than bishops
but uh you know but i want to i want to
try to get it on the light squares
because in these kind of uh openings
especially when you play e4 white's
light square bishop is such a tremendous
piece
and uh by by taking the bishop i i would
open up the light squares but
it's not ready i feel for that quite yet
i'd also like to say just prague i mean
i was just working out that he he's uh
unbelievable isn't it i mean and he's
playing magnus tomorrow start of the
week on a monday that is going to be
such a great match because magnus is
going to try to show him who's boss
pride's going to be like right okay i'm
playing so well i can't wait and he's
won um
22 and a half thousand um
dollars already yeah so which is pretty
pretty impressive right so it's uh yeah
not bad for three days work so uh yeah
just gotta set that alarm for tomorrow
at six o'clock cet
when those two faces off in a big big
clash i what do you think it's gonna be
for magnus will he sort of feel the
pressure on that one for sure especially
if magnus isn't feeling a hundred
percent uh if he's still not feeling
fully healthy remember prague beat him
two months ago uh in the tour so
he's definitely i think magnus would
love to escape that uh
that match up with maybe tie breaks and
i was going to say escape that match up
with a draw but we do find a winner at
the end of every day
i think at this point anyone taking
pride to tie breaks is going to be a
miracle he just looks so good so i yeah
just to catch up with this game no rook
takes bishop which is a really nice kind
of long-term strategic sacrifice to win
all the light squares but comes at the
cost of a rook of course uh for a bishop
instead eric takes the sensible way out
and develops this piece so both these
two white bishops are looking good
and next he'll try and move his queen
out the way maybe connect the two white
rooks um yeah just looking very balanced
i'm pretty sure at some point in the
next few moves uh shaq is going to push
this pawn forward one thing you can't
really allow is the white knight to leap
into your position and then continue its
journey uh into the black camp this
square is actually a bit of a target now
with the white knight and with the white
bishop so just push this pawn maybe try
and expand on this side
and uh yeah a lot to play for but still
equal at the moment yeah and i agree the
position is going to hinge on who
maneuvers their pieces in the best
possible way because as you can see no
pawns in the center so all the energy
transfers to the pieces and uh whilst
uh shakura is pondering what to do well
we have some selfies i want to share and
the first one comes from neil young
who says not quite the musician but it
says me and ricky are tuning in again so
big hello to you
to you neil and ricky and
ashish vega raju says that they were
enjoying the game between magnus carlsen
and anish from the netherlands and we
can see a move from mamajarov retreating
the bishop actually allowing the knight
to just spring into this
the black side of the board
yeah i think it's okay for now that can
just be kind of refuted by black's
knight coming to the center of the board
hitting white's dart squad bishop and
the game will go on so no real big
threats here but uh yeah slightly
surprisingly from madora i think i think
we need more pet selfies i think so too
this is like one thing we're lacking
here we're getting lots of selfies but i
want to see some pets in front i do like
the pet selfies i also really like it
when the players multi the players the
viewers multitask and they try and
combine watching our show with maybe
watching the allen partridge show or as
jmr18 says chess and nba playoffs makes
a great sunday evening ah that's not bad
also can we have some extreme watching
photos what's the most extreme place
that someone could take a selfie
watching the show even if it's on their
phone like a roller coaster
in the middle of a football match
climbing a mountain abba sailing maybe
sailing we've had a few from sailing
we've had a few on an oil rig that was
pretty cool
yeah i'd like to see some of them i
think you know there should be a price
that the most extreme
watching of uh who will go to the moon
to watch chess is the question elon we
need you
he's a chess fan right yeah yeah he is a
chess fan yeah i think he said it was a
simple game in his last tweet about it
though he said oh it's an easy game or
something
but he doesn't really know anything
about it
my dream is seeing elon musk take on
magnus age 10.
if you're watching elon a challenge for
you come on and play magnus 10. yeah it
could be interesting
and
meanwhile the knight has moved to the
center of the board and is now attacking
white's dark squared bishop
and
whilst we do whilst we're waiting for
eric to respond to this i also have a
question from duncan bailey who asks do
all of the players in the oslo esports
cup have seconds with them or are some
attempting this without support
well eric actually i haven't he
he's alone in oslo it's very surprising
that isn't it because he's got his all
his crew as well um but they probably
are working for him right
well there's a few people who are alone
so liam lay i haven't seen him with a
second magnus doesn't have anyone
physical physically here with him yeah
um the rest of the players you see
jordan he's working with johan sebastian
christiansen yep on
[Music]
yep
so half and half actually yeah
but i'm sure everyone is working behind
the scenes with someone this is the
beauty of chess these days you know you
don't need someone physically present
you can also
have a helper working remotely yeah and
do you need at the top level of chess
now do you need a second or a team of
seconds in big tournaments
i'm not sure you need it but it
definitely helps it's a bit of a bonus i
mean it's not just for the chess right
it's for the psychological staff
especially now they play so many games
in one day you need to recover quickly
you don't want to finish one game go
into your room turn on the computer and
then kind of start from scratch every
time you want to come in and have
someone you know put their arm around
you or say okay
this is your next opening
you'll love this position you can do it
um yeah it's it sounds like it's uh kind
of
uh maybe kind of a give or take you can
have a second or not but i think it's it
gives you the extra edge because it must
be very for example a niche it's
disappointed today it didn't really go
his way today
it would have been very
lonely to bring all your negative
thoughts back to your hotel and just be
by yourself right it must be nice to
have someone to just talk it out get rid
of the bad emotions it's one of the
worst feelings like losing a game of
chess and i think this is very hard to
describe to people who don't play chess
i mean if you've had relationships with
non-chess players it's it's you know
horrible for them to when you lose the
game and you have to go and see them
because you're in such a bad mood
and
it's very hard to understand that i
don't know
maybe we've all had that at some point
but the feeling of losing is is
incredible and uh they also say like you
know
that feeling it's not the same as
winning you know the feeling of winning
is great but they don't really level out
you know that it's horrible i mean david
i mean i don't want to bring you up but
i'm going to because you've been so
because you've been so close to
qualifying for the candidates on a
couple occasions and it must have been
heartbreaking for you many yeah there
have been many times in my life where i
just felt extremely lonely having lost a
game in a foreign country
not home for a long time and
yeah it's it's devastating and earlier
we mentioned this podcast we did with
anishkiri actually we we talked to eric
hanson as well and eric talked a lot
about mental health and uh it's actually
it's not talked about as much among the
top chess players but it's so important
that's why you bring seconds with you
that's why you have a support network
that's why magnus for example is so good
he has his family he has a set of
coaches around him that's maybe why
prague's doing so well now with ramesh
but eric he mentioned the reason he
streams more than plays chess uh kind of
classical competitive chess these days
is because he finds it lonely he finds
it difficult stressful having to win
just to earn money and living out of a
suitcase it's uh yeah it's a difficult
lifestyle at the top level so at those
occasions that
where you were very close to qualifying
for the candidates this this fall was
actually one of those occasions were you
alone at that time or did you have a
second with you yeah i've never really
brought a second with me i think only
maybe twice to any tournaments um but
yeah i've pretty much worked alone most
of the time since i was 12 years old
just kind of self-taught and
my parents came with me of course when i
was young but
yeah it was time it was tough um i mean
the second time i nearly qualified for
candidates i was more kind of objective
about it i thought okay i wasn't ready
and farouza caron are the only two place
players i lost to
i mean it's because they're stronger uh
than me but the first time i didn't
qualify i was on my own and i locked
myself in my room just
uh i don't want to tell you what i was
thinking there but it was uh yeah
difficult do we do we simply not talk
about it enough i mean it's become a big
theme in in other sports we've seen it
in tennis and gymnastics in the olympics
more athletes talking about mental
health are we not talking about it
enough in chess where maybe is even a
bigger issue
because it is a mind sport i think it's
definitely a conversation that you know
doesn't come up enough yeah and it's a
conversation to have i mean fidei could
talk about it maybe put on some support
for players i know lots of former
players when they kind of stop and
retire or when their careers maybe don't
go as far as they can uh yeah it's
difficult for them
feed recently they've been supporting i
think chess plays who are struggling
financially who
things like that but the mental side
that's a big part of it yeah absolutely
it's definitely an important subject
that i personally think that federation
should be dealing with especially when
they're sending their elite players to
events and they know full well that
often these elite players are dependent
on that money and they're dependent on
winning and everything is hanging on the
edge so i i agree with david there it
should be a conversation that we have um
measures should be taken there should
you know we should it should be budgeted
for and also you know chess players as
well
should also be not too proud and say
there is a problem
and we should admit to that and like
david says often we're alone in the
rooms and it can get a bit dark yeah but
uh
yeah i mean hopefully things are
changing i mean it really helps to have
top players like eric hansen openly
discussingly discussing this
and i mean the same goes with women in
chess as well you know top women are
beginning to discuss some of the issues
and a lot of us are kind of saying yeah
okay we are struggling with this
help us and it's great to have that
conversation yeah
no i totally agree i mean i think mel
mental health in general is uh something
that's been not chatted about in life as
much as it should be uh the old way
looking it was a weakness which is
clearly not the not the issue now and
chess is a mental game so it needs to be
uh it's all in the mind and i think
even your performance um
if you're mentally okay you'll play a
lot better and uh you know i've seen
lots of chess players suffer from having
uh been very affected from losses and
just the lifestyle which is exciting but
it's also where you know if you're
playing to win your rent and it doesn't
go right you know and i've seen players
sleeping in the public toilets
at chess tournaments yeah
at big chess tournaments because they
can't afford it not a very healthy
lifestyle but there's the other side
there's a you know there is a glamorous
side to it as well but i think yeah 100
it needs to be
talked about more in general as well as
in chess yeah and there are even stories
of former world champions who kind of
they turn to drink they turn to other
vices um just because they couldn't cope
with the pressures and um
yeah that's something to talk about yeah
i mean like bobby fischer is one of them
you know you know he went a little bit a
little bit
totally mad at the end and
it feels like it's almost been joked
about that the best chess players
it's it's going to affect their sanity
because they're so in their head but
it's actually a very serious
subject to not joke about definitely
with bobby fischer i mean especially
when you kind of think about the nature
of competition you know there is that
shadow side which you know it divides
people into winners and losers i mean
you have to address the mental side
absolutely such an important subject and
the podcast the late night show with um
eric hansen talking about this together
with david and oscar will be released
later this upcoming week
so that's going to be interesting to to
listen to and we're going to talk some
more about it when that is released
eric looking very focused right now this
is game four between himself and
chakriar and mohammed yarov they are
tied in their match we could be heading
to tie breaks what do you think right
now david we could be although i really
like what eric's been doing okay so the
position has changed slightly it's still
roughly a symmetrical pawn structure but
one big change now on the king side so
on the right half of the board where the
king sit um there has been a trade a
night for a bishop and that means an
imbalance white also has a set of double
pawns which could be a strength could be
a weakness um but i prefer white purely
because i'm uh biased towards the bishop
pair and white's bishop especially the
light squared bishop which has no rival
right now um it's got a lot of potential
i think shaq now mamidarov has to be
really careful he has to be really
energetic with his play just to balance
out the effect of white's bishops okay
he just pushes a pawn there to cover
some light squares around his king but
eric now he can bring a rook into the
game his rook asleep in the corner maybe
you could make an argument for using
white's dark squared bishop attacking
the black queen
lots of options for eric yeah i mean i
think one thing actually earlier on we
were saying it's very equal but one of
the issues that black's had from i don't
know move move six or seven is this pawn
uh on c5 maybe cannot just highlight
that
and often having a pawn here is a
weakness um because this pawn here
you can't move pawns backwards so you
leave a lot of holes and you leave the
central square next to that open
i totally agree with david eric's got
very good chances here he couldn't
really have asked for anything better
it's a safe way to play that bishop that
david has uh highlighted now can't be
blocked by that pawn and it's a
fantastic bishop and black doesn't have
a bishop to try and act against it so
we're a perfect position right for eric
ivanka because
he's got the bishops he shouldn't lose
this and he can just play normal moves
and try to nurture that advantage here
i agree uh i love the plans that you're
suggesting and like you say you know
he's a pla plenty of plans at his
disposal you know probe the the right
side for some dark square weaknesses or
how has he done now he's actually
played very interesting very nice
movement we saw how dreadful the pawn
structure was a double pawn structure
was in the anish geary against magnus
carlsen game
game two
and here eric is threatening to do more
of the same
win a piece as well it's not just that
the white queen indirectly attacks this
black knight which is a bit loose it's
only defended by black's queen and yeah
as mentioned if black just makes a kind
of careless move bishop takes knight not
only ruins the black pawn structure but
after it's captured this knight falls
off as well so white's queen is kind of
using her x-ray vision on both sides of
the board uh this queen now super strong
eyeing up this night and this knight and
i think black needs to move this guy
it's just too vulnerable on this square
it's on a great attacking square but
nothing to attack and it's fighting a
lone battle on its own in white's half i
think it needs to step back and retreat
otherwise
oh even here actually does this lose a
pawn um okay i was gonna say this move
but maybe white can capture here and
some complications ahead uh so okay
instead shaq insists on keeping his
knight in white's half but this does
allow eric if he wants to maybe just
capture this knight and ruin the black
pawn structure
looking very good for eric suddenly
definitely i mean he can capture the
other night first so he wants to keep it
very simple i think
true and just start grabbing some pawns
um for example here i mean i'm not sure
which way black takes does he take with
a bishop maybe and then after this move
black can't even take with the queen
because black has to keep guarding his
bishop and suddenly pawn takes oh look
at these guys over here they're just
gonna drop one by one you can even take
one of them right now
it seems like white's knight is
incredibly strong at stopping any
threats
okay he's done the other way in the game
the only reason i want to play that
exchange from white i know i'm giving up
my bishop is the black knight looks a
bit scary to me he has some tactical
ideas so why not just get rid of your
opponent's most scariest piece very
simply get rid of that piece that's
scary i'm safe and i've got targets to
pick up so this is going to be one of
eric's best chances to
get a brilliant win against a brilliant
player i feel he's played an amazing
game so far eric but only two and a half
minutes so he needs to keep the pace and
i agree with you simon just get this
night off the board don't take any risks
uh of it for example jumping in to
deliver a nasty check um just get rid of
your opponent's best attacking piece and
he does it yeah very logical and uh once
shaq re-takes with the queen or with the
bishop uh eric can start maybe feasting
on some of those weak pawns he's gonna
take with the queen and uh yep on the
board even this end game even tricky
training the queens off looks fantastic
for white very nice safe way to play if
you take the queens off get your knight
to c4 at some point and win
um but can you grab a pawn first i mean
uh yeah yeah
i gave a big smile
i've got to get you to sing once you've
got much better voice of me okay okay go
for it no no no i'm just saying okay
look at the movie
it's on the board he's grabbed the pawn
so sing
[Laughter]
you sound like a lot of people in the
chat sometimes yeah
i was trying to do catherine tate you
know she's like oh are we doing this
anyway
okay
so there has been a bit of a
transformation of the position eric did
go and grab some of those pawns so
ivanka was right no more end games it's
time to get greedy and
one downside to this is that the queens
remain on the board so your king now as
white doesn't feel entirely safe
and the other downside is that black
does have a poor majority now on the
king's side so you have to be a bit
careful eric he wants to trade off rooks
that's why he brought his queen back he
maybe wants to bring his rook to the top
of the board give a check
trade some rooks off and queen a knight
against queen a bishop should be a
winning endgame also centralizing the
queen looks like the queen that's very
because i guess mamajara's idea is to
push the jeep on what else can you do
you want to try to get rid of that very
strong knight um so then maybe eric just
brings his queen back you can see on his
face look at eric's face he's really
determined he realizes this is a chance
to win seven and a half thousand dollar
dollars which is incredible an
incredible amount so i think he's in the
zone now beating one of the world's best
players a several time candidate
mamadourov
yeah i mean this would be a huge win for
eric and he's
very close yeah oh he doesn't want those
tie breaks he looks so focused you know
it's almost like chess is like some kind
of meditation for him right now he's
just concentrating on the next move
and uh not that much that shakurya can
do and so he steps his king forward
do you think uh eric will go for his
plan trade queens it looks like he's
about to play irvanco you can see his
screen right now okay clicked the queen
and he brought her back to offer that
trade
very safe
then start pushing your past pawns i
guess i mean there's that that you know
that word you've got passport you need
to push them get another queen so uh
now's the time right yeah why not
there's no frets you could even go g3
king g2 if you want to be nice
look at his screen he's about to he's
gonna do it he's i think he's in the
zone he's finding brilliant moves here
isn't he
such a safe way to blunt the bishop get
your king safe and he has played it i
mean that's just a really nice way to
play actually so smooth and uh i
remember the first time i heard eric
hansen's name was years and years ago i
was playing a lot online at the time and
i just played against this guy who just
kept outplaying me sometimes i would
trick him when he had no time but every
game he would outplay me strategically
and that nearly never happens and then i
was like who's this guy a canadian flag
next to him i found out a year or two
later it was eric hansen
and uh yeah ever since i mean he was two
years younger than me
just uh ever since then i've just
realized he's just a great understanding
of chess
yeah he's so talented
yeah i mean he's doing everything
perfectly here at the moment so uh you
know
very good game so far very good game we
should mention that this is a really
nice strategy of putting the white king
on a light square away from the black
bishop and also making sure there are no
background checkmates later on and oh
this is desperate from mamadyarov
there's putting a pawn under dart square
but now there are light square
weaknesses
yeah it comes
[Laughter]
attacking the white queen but the white
queen can move the white rook at the
bottom of the board is actually defended
by the knight so um this isn't a skewer
or it's nothing too scary here for eric
he just needs to find a safe square for
the white queen yeah his position is uh
eric's position is just safe as houses
nothing can go wrong
like something can always go wrong
maybe there's one trap in the position
if you move your queen to the wrong
square then the black pawn can come down
and attack the white knight so you need
to keep an eye on that black g pawn
pushing forward that's why eric kept his
queen on the fourth rank controlling
every important square
you know queen on a light square nice
outpost there yeah eric with two minutes
should be enough so eric is he's turning
30 this year right yeah and a couple of
months ago yeah um
but we're just now starting to see him
in these
big competitions with the best chess
players in the world are we seeing the
start of eric hansen even if he is
reaching 30 years old
hopefully yeah i mean he's always been a
very strong player kind of a very strong
ground master but
i've experienced it myself when you're
in the kind of 2600 rating range you
don't get the invitations to these top
tournaments so eric he he kind of
he got an invitation here struck gold
and performed really well
he's been a fan favorite his whole
career so
especially now that chess is becoming
more of an e-sport which suits him now
it's becoming more of a kind of
spectator sport i think that suits him
for a chess coming to him
the format that suits him the very best
is now invented i mean i think one very
important thing i think he needs to be
invited to more events just for the fact
that he's entertaining and he's an
entertaining player and i've seen so
many top tournaments where they invite
the same players over and over again and
let's be honest they're really boring to
watch
they might be much stronger player than
eric but i don't want to watch them
because it's draw draw oh my god you
know i want to see eric um fighting and
uh this is the new generation as well
players who are making chess popular so
um yeah so let's hope he continues with
that i wholeheartedly agree with simon
you know it makes a big difference when
you invite the right players you know we
saw then the air things masters as well
you know there was like a bunch of young
talents and eric of course did really
really well and it was exciting they
fought to the end you know there were no
13 moves draws you know in fact i think
it was only magnus and ding who were
guilty of that and that was a sensible
moment yeah yeah exactly and it was just
one time
and uh now you see another fight to the
end yeah and i did see him shake his
head though he's getting nervous
he's getting nervous he realizes that
he's he's probably winning
and he realizes he's very close and
that's the worst time it's like that
thing they say when everyone has
accidents in their car it's like when
you get into your road and you're near
your home you could do a 200 mile
journey it's the last one mile where
everyone has an accident because they
relax
and i think uh you know he's just got to
keep that concentration up here
yeah and uh okay very solid move there
protecting his pawns he's still one pawn
up eric but it's more about the queen
and knight combo the domination of the
light squares everything in his favor
uh and okay is he about to push a pawn
forward this black bishop now attacking
one of white's pawns if you block up the
pawn structure though on that left side
it does make it slightly more difficult
to make progress so eric reluctant to
play this next move keeping his pawn
safe it's the nerves you can see on his
body language shaking his head
he was so focused now suddenly a bit of
hesitation he's under a minute he's
under a minute i mean i i know
things can't go wrong it was said but
like i said they can always go wrong
when you get nervous anything can go
wrong you know it really yeah he was
about to play a very kind of
passive move there bringing his rook to
defend the white pawns
uh yeah it's definitely nerfs 30 seconds
now yeah
this is still and also shakira has a
reputation as being one of the most
dangerous players there is you know he's
so tactically alert and uh yeah he's
moved his rook thankfully not to a
passive square instead he's going on the
counter attack always go active if you
have uh the option you never want to put
your pieces in purely defensive roles
that white rook worth five in the middle
of the board now look how active it is
attacking pawns on open files he was
about to put it on a really bad square
where it it really wouldn't have been
worth five uh so okay great decision
from eric he invested a lot of time in
though in that move and 35 seconds
shaq at some point will try to set a
trap so it's just about whether eric can
dodge his nerves uh minimize the effect
of them and also dodge any traps
i think white's knight as well needs to
re-route itself at some point maybe h2 i
was thinking is is a good way you can
maybe change targets towards black king
because the black king is a little bit
weak and it's when you're in a stressful
situation it's actually quite easy to
attack
rather than sort of defend your
opponent's little threats just get
attacking uh but you know as long as he
keeps his call he will win this game
yeah and uh especially while the black
queen and black rook are kind of
sidelined distracted over there dealing
with white spawns
switching your attention to the black
king i mean that would be the most
logical thing in the world so is now the
moment to reroute the white knight do
you have to take a time out too under 20
seconds david yeah he has 20 seconds
come on
you know i also think it's tempting to
maneuver the the white knight but at the
same time you might be thinking it's a
little bit passive
in 10 seconds okay okay he's pushed his
pawn forward that does mean that those
pawns on the left they're not that going
to be that easy to advance they're fixed
now and that's why he's shaking his head
but he still has so many other
advantages it's not just about the
number of pawns it's about the
domination of the light squares so if he
can re-route his knight if you can pick
up the white knight and plug it on the
f5 square
knight and f5 will thrive that's just
going to be game over he should be
loving this position but it's just the
nerves yeah i mean it's it's it's
horrible yeah
well it's actually really exciting as
well at the same time
he is used to playing under 20 seconds
but i don't think he's used to being in
these positions where it's the only game
we're all watching him yeah it must be
lonely out there in the arena yeah um
it's just the two of them with all the
bright lights all the cameras 10 seconds
okay 10 seconds
come on and uh shaq responding really
quickly activating his rook here we go
here we go yes the knight remaneuvers
and he plays it and it's a mistake is
that right is it a mistake
i don't see anything wrong with it maybe
there was something even better but no
this look i mean this looks like
completely the right plan the knight
going for the square david mentioned
which would be a fantastic square
if he gets it there that should be the
game over i feel like look out for that
f5 square if the knight ever arrives
there i think it's going to be game over
time for mama jarv just simply to
improve the dark square bishop
put it on
the d4 square i think he's got to try
the good thing about eric's position as
well is that his rook and queen are
dominating the center of the board and
when you dominate the center
you stop your opponent's pieces coming
in
so he's just got to keep them there
dominating all the way and um if you're
fighting against one bishop then occupy
the opposite color complex okay shakurya
he's i don't think that's a good move
but it's a scary move for eric to face
because suddenly the rook is in his uh
in his camp
it's penetrated to the first rank and
okay he's about to kick it away with his
knight but oh he's come back he did too
oh no is that oh but hang on a second
now the rock doesn't have to stay on the
e line it can actually maneuver itself
to a different square i'm thinking
primarily the c1 square and it's on the
board so that's a big now there's a big
threat the rook is going to lift itself
two squares backwards and attack the
queen and the pawn and if that b3 pawn
drops well anything can happen anything
can happen okay but this is eric to
strike first and the rook on the seventh
rank is where you want the rook and
there's a major target right next to
black's king so this is where eric might
be able to transfer one advantage into
an attack uh where i think he'd be happy
but he's got 22 seconds by the way hello
to harry the pet there as well
so hi harry um but yeah is eric gonna do
it guys
he's still the big favorite here despite
having 22 seconds on the clock it's just
the momentum it's changed slightly maybe
can you just go queen d5 so
if you get a bit worried you can play
safe go queen d5 get the queens off
you're a pawn up in the ending and you
you can calm down a little bit there
other thoughts that being said if the
queens disappear black does have a
bishop which is maybe superior to a
night when pawns on both sides of the
board in an end game
and uh
yeah white's knight currently at least
for now dominated by that black bishop
it can't jump forward anywhere so that's
the big decision and i think oh wow shaq
under one minute as well 40 seconds i
think that's what they're both
calculating shaq wants to move his queen
of course he has to it's attacked but
he's calculating any potential queen
trade gone for it he has to go for it i
think and uh well eric did not change
the queens i prefer this yeah he's this
is a much more uh um
ultimate kind of solution but it's much
more complicated and
yeah 30 seconds each definitely the
stakes are getting higher and i really
like this move that shakura has
displayed you know retreating the queen
that's true but
there are some potential ideas of the
queen diving in along the e2 square i
mean eric yeah i mean eric's got to
surely come in with his queen now isn't
he has to do that 12 seconds 11 seconds
yeah start creating frets bring the
queen in seven seconds oh oh what's he
done he's gone
onto a dark square as well the white
queen loves those light squares it might
be a good move but it is a little bit
negative um you know if black does get
the queen over into the position as well
then eric's going to come under some
attack i'm a little bit afraid of moves
like uh the rook sliding to the b1
square attacking a pawn and then you
know a move that david highlighted just
attacking the night away he's gone okay
he's gone for it trying to get the rook
onto the certain rank eric has to be
really careful now some big threats
coming up again seven seconds he's taken
this wow is that genius he's oh is that
madness he's giving up his rook for a
bishop if the black king comes out into
the open and takes it eric has got some
checks lined up wow he's got a very
clever check on c3 i think maybe this is
just just this could be a brilliant move
yeah he can run
um how did he see i mean now shaq is
down to five seconds
he's just given up the game he's a night
down eric nine seconds about to make a
huge
just he's going to win this game yeah
he's going to win yeah now the black
pawn attacking the white knight but the
white knight could just park itself on
the side of the board go forwards or go
straight yeah that's good
keep attacking move forward and park
yourself next to that
to the edge that's fine it's all right
okay okay black's queen can now deliver
a check at least okay i mean black's
gonna get checked mate threat though the
rook coming in yeah which is all scary
and knight is a king's best friend that
beautiful night can oh no not yet oh
okay okay shaq is threatening checkmate
10 seconds on the board the black rook
and black queen want to get into the
corner of the board so you have to block
the queen's diagonal still winning for
spit it's scary the white king is now
exposed he's winning but it's a little
bit scary at least now he has a night
check coming in white's knight was
threatening to come and check the black
king so marijuana had to lose a move
retreating his king he's going for the
final kill he's got it has he got it
he's got it well done and it's a
celebration from eric hanson the chess
streamer